le taekwondo sport de combat d'origine
sud-coréenne était à l'honneur ce
week-end à trappes 300 sportifs ont
participé au championnat ile de france
seniors et à la coupe de france vétérans
gymnase paul mallet une habitude pour le
club local
on a eu l'occasion de faire
quatre compétitions déjà la première ça
a été un dépannage et
je pense que voilà l'accueil le
professionnalisme aussi d argent de la
ville de trappes
tout ça fait que aujourd'hui on
accueille encore cidf au sein du gymnase
la compétition deuxième étape
qualificative pour les championnats de
france a attiré des têtes d'affiché de
la discipline dans la catégorie des plus
de 87 kg ce énième beau membre de
l'équipe de france depuis 2007 et ancien
coéquipier de pascal gentil aux jo de
pékin en 2008 s'est inscrit pour cet
événement c'est la complète il faut
faire pour faire les championnats de
france donc c'est les qualificatifs en
fait les championnats régional pour se
qualifier aux championnats france encore
sur obligé de les faire donc c'est pour
ça
des sportifs renommés mais également des
stars en devenir ont combattu ce
week-end pour les détecter et suivre
leur évolution des recruteurs ont fait
le déplacement
on peut éventuellement recruter ou
sélectionner des partenaires
d'entraînement pour les équipes
nationales en préparation sur des
objectifs majeurs comme les championnats
du monde chanteur de rock ou
éventuellement les jeux olympiques
le club de trappes accueillerait
également l'open labellisé ile de france
les 18 et 19 février une autre étape
qualificative pour les championnats de
france